hello there late last year i told you
about a new free-to-play battle royale
which is unlike all the others rumble
verse a pro wrestling inspired br called
a brawler royale so if you've ever
thought fortnite would be better without
firearms rumbleverse is pretty much that
the game is now fast approaching release
with a few final tests going on i jumped
in to give you a preview an example of a
typical game let me know your thoughts
please and here we go
welcome to graphite city rumble versus
island of battle just like most other
brs the playing area shrinks forcing all
players closer together what's unlike
other battle royales is the method to
get on the island cannons we fire
ourselves across the ocean and free fall
wherever we see fit we then land and
beat the living daylights out of each
other early game is all about upgrading
your character as you see fit crates are
littered everywhere with goodies inside
literal loot boxes you must smash open
to know what's inside a weapon like a
chair or a plank of wood a book and a
drink of some sort you already know what
to do with the weapon this is wwe pick
them up and break them on someone's face
it's the other two things which deserve
our attention by reading a book we can
learn a new wrestling move we can learn
two in total from a sumo slap to a pile
driver and my personal favorite a kick
to the junk a very high quality
wrestling maneuver the thing to remember
is our puny wrestler brain can only hold
two moves learning anything past that
point pushes an old one out
[Music]
in the early game we are usually
contested and must fight so let's break
down how that works it's a super simple
system of just two buttons one for
strikes one for grapples a three-hit
combo or a simple maneuver like this if
both players press the same button at
the same time it will end in this recoil
and you're back to step one if one
player presses strike and the other
presses grapple then the strike will win
out nice and simple right those are the
building blocks but then we have the
ability to block strikes but that block
cannot block a grapple it's kind of like
rock paper scissors at its core choosing
the right button for the right time and
to add to this we have a dodge maneuver
which can avoid attacks but timing seems
to be based on your internet connection
which is a little bit of a worry
rumble verse has the pick up and play
simplicity but also prompts you to study
your opponent and find loops in their
behavior reading their play style this
makes every match unique well until
you're third partied it's a br after all
that's what people do
here going back to those crates and the
mythical potions inside there are three
in total red green and yellow the red
ones give you a power boost to all your
attacks the green ones give you
additional health and the yellow ones
are stamina everyone hates stamina bars
so let's break that down
almost everything in rumbleverse uses
stamina from strikes to running to
climbing a building oh yeah you can
scale buildings in rumbleverse run out
of stamina and the character will become
winded making you a sitting duck for
others to pound on so by drinking those
yellow drinks you will increase your
stamina meter permanently over the
course of the game we can drink up to 10
of these tonics to create our overall
build if you choose 10 red drinks you
will become a powerhouse and probably
get more limbs if you choose the green
drink you will have so much health
you'll be able to tank more shots than
the rest of the lobby and if you choose
the yellow drinks your stamina will help
you run around freely and dodge more
attacks most likely you'll choose a
blend of all three of these to make your
ultimate build oh we never spoke about
skins check this out rumbleverse is
planning a battle pass as a way to make
money from its free-to-play starting
point which means we need customization
we start with six body types i'm going
to call these three male and three
female one is slender one is muscular
and one is so thick it's clinically
obese we have the usual bunch of skin
colors to choose from and eyebrows but
the real interest comes from clothing
regardless of what garment you choose it
will morph into the chosen body shape
here's an overweight racing driver
only a small number of the cosmetics
were shown at this early point but the
range was quite impressive from knee
pads to wrist straps from hair buns to
bright pink beards customization looks
to be the biggest asset rumble verse has
to offer back to the fighting so you've
been absolutely battered and you're one
hit from elimination luckily you've
escaped surprisingly health does not
regenerate naturally in rumble verse
instead we need to consume something and
in this game it's chicken another item
which can be found in the crate munch on
these to gain a portion of your health
back the trick is to find chicken as
early as possible and store it in your
inventory we have four pockets four
slots to use at any point keep a cheeky
chair in there for later or a booster
item or four chickens if you like you do
you one thing is for certain utilizing
inventory space is key to reaching the
final circles if you're lucky for
something else rumble verse how super
moves during a typical game you'll
notice a super move is accessible
through this prompt to build this meter
up simply pick up all the stars which
are scattered absolutely everywhere on
the island you also gain them from all
the fights you get into when pushed your
character will super saiyan and your
speed stamina and damage output go
through the roof for a limited amount of
time if you see someone use one of these
run for your life and wait for it to
expire because if they get a hold of you
this will happen crazy damage oh street
fighter 2 reference zangief would be
very proud
a cool trick you should know is that if
you don't use your super move and
instead hold on to it if you are
defeated your super move will be
activated bringing you back to life like
a second wind you see in the wwe full-on
undertaker sit up and back into the
fight so do you use your super move or
do you hold on to it just in case so i'm
sure you've noticed the physics here are
outrageous i mean cars are literal
springboards and we don't take fall
damage but height does play an important
part in the game a simple suplex chips
away at a player's health do this from
the top of a building and the damage is
multiplied rumble verse encourages us to
jump from a 30-stary building grappling
another player another cool thing i saw
during the preview was a wrestling move
onto a car which then sprang both
players into the air before speeding
back down to earth completely over the
top rumbleverse has a final public test
in july before hopefully fingers crossed
releasing soon after that please let me
know if you want me to cover this in
future i'll end with a compilation of
all the ways i was eliminated rip the
dream
okay my strap my pro strat this time is
to just hide in a corner of the circle
and get first place simple as peace
right stamina oh this is a bad i needed
more stamina to do this
i am completely winded out of stamina
anyone can hit me i can't block oh no
not like this
nothing like this
the strap was perfect
this time i'm gonna hide in the corn no
i'm not
right get back in i've got so much
health it doesn't matter oh god let me
back in let me back in no
it's gonna happen isn't it oh no
no
no i just got disqualified with all this
help ouch
well there's always listen i'll talk
about that
but you
not the best
what if he can hide in bushes can anyone
see me
yes
yes
i'm not very good at this game